[Music]
you shot a new film called the duel with
Woody Harrelson yes and of course you've
worked with Woody Harrelson before yeah
is he a fun guy to be on a film shoot
with he's the funnest he's the best yeah
we got we became really good friends on
the Hunger Games we shot a bunch of
those together obviously and then and
then right at the end of the Hunger
Games he said that he had this script
which was a Western that he was going to
do and yet I sent it over and we ended
up doing it together and it was we shot
it out in Mississippi Greenwood which
it's kind of out in the middle of
nowhere a lovely lovely place lovely
people but sort of not a lot to do on
the weekend so we would often take his
bus which is a converted old school bus
this is woody this is belong woody
harrelson he hung bus he has his own bus
but it's like you know one of those
yellow school buses but it's not yellow
anymore
it has a big sign on the front that says
the mothership and and it's painted with
all like naked hippies and animals and
flowers and rainbows and fun and you
know we would drive that bus to
something fun every weekend and when
you're on the bus on this on the
mothership with woody what kind of stuff
are you doing you know hanging out
hanging out doing woody woody harrelson
hobbies and I've saw that bus too and
it's it's upholstered in all hemp yeah
everything in the bus is all HAMP's Oh
him yeah I guess we can probably figure
out what you guys yeah yeah yeah I like
how you called them AR oson hobbies
that's a nice way to put it yeah and who
would you it would you go ever cuz he he
seems like he's friends with everyone
would you get his friends yeah he's
friends with everyone and and he is one
of his good friends is Willie Nelson
it's all becoming so redundant and Snoop
Dogg stopped by
Cheech and Chong came by oh yes yeah so
if we went to a Willie Nelson concert
one weekend we drove a couple hours to
Willie Nelson and we jumped on Willie
Nelson's his to Abbas because he was
touring around be great if those two
buses could merge we pull up right next
to Billy's and we came off our bus and
plowed a smoke and then went on to his
bus in another cloud of smoke yeah no
I'd like it if it just they merged as
like like transformers like they came
together and made a giant kooky hippie
yet high bus yeah it was 3,000 feet long
the biggest bong in the world
you